just make sure on global climate' that
we're talking about more than climate
and that you understand what climate
means there's a great argument that
global climate change which has become
warmer has actually been a real positive
we have less people freezing to death
even though we have some that are dying
is that where the highest priority for
our resources Israel or is it fighting
million malnutrition malnutrition around
the world or is it fighting malaria
around the world or hiv/aids if you gave
me 200 billion dollars to go spend over
the next 10 years global climate would
be the last place I had put that money
it would be in the malnutrition it would
be in the malaria it would be in
hiv/aids that's what we need to decide
as a world it's sort of like giving a
new heart to a ninety-year-old do you
give that new heart to a ten-year-old
ready to give it to 90 year old you've
got to make choices because there are
limited resources at the end of the day
and if I'm going to end up being taxed
for a hundred billion dollars worth of
cost is a consuming nation of energy I
want to make sure those taxes go to the
best places we can for the world's
wealth can help health and welfare an
aye vote for doing that on the side of
hunger and disease way before I try to
create try to fight the fiction that I
think has been hoisted honest about what
co2 is really doing and we have to
absolutely educate ourselves just as I'm
doing right now about what is really
causing the problem is it actually heat
the warmth of the globe causing co2 to
rise or is it co2 causing the heat of
globe to go up and importantly if it is
going up because of man-made emissions
is it all bad or is it actually arguably
some what good is the Arctic actually
melting because of the wind changes or
because of co2 is the Antarctic actually
losing five percent of its ice in one
part and growing out ninety-five percent
more make sure we get all the points of
the story and that we don't have special
interest groups lobbying groups whether
it's the oil industry whether it's the
environmental movement or whether it's
politicians or other NGOs telling us how
the world ought to work let's get
educated all of us on
our own and get past the rhetoric and
actually make tough tough economic
choices based on where our heart says
the world ought to go